lizzo and Jack Black appeared on the
Disney Star Wars show despicable Jeff
that is at the clock calling the
stiffing slimy I beg your pardon this
planet is unrecognizable since he
arrived
I had a feeling you hated me I'm
disappointed in you commissioner you
served my family well but Captain
Bombardier is the love of my life and I
know his heart is true
sure he's made some mistakes in the past
but who here Among Us has not
is there no room for a little bit of
forgiveness in a galaxy so vast
who's watching this I saw this clip and
I real I had to double check because I
honestly first thought it was a skill
that was like an SNL skit or something
and uh and then I I verified no that's
that's actually the show like that's the
show it's that's what Disney is putting
out